Jocko, how do you give feedback to someone
without everyone taking it personal?
I try to give criticism regarding their
work or actions while not attacking
their character, but unfortunately
many feel that it's personal.
Yeah,
welcome to the world.
People don't like crisen criticism and
I almost put a no one in the world like
skepticism.
Okay,
so there might be 1e-05% of the world
that's really like open and ready for
feedback. Right? But most
people, even when they,
even when they tell you they want
feedback, they don't want it.
They don't want it. Like, let me, let me
give an example. If you echo Charles, yes.
We're like you. You made a video and it
took you an hour. Don't even don't even,
right. You know what I'm saying? Like
you could come to me and say, Hey,
what do you think? And I was
like, well, you know, I think
you framed this up wrong.
How w what's your reaction to that?
I mean,
there's no possible way that you're
stoked on that. They're just now, luckily,
you know, we know each other.
You can detach and be like,
all right, let me do. He's,
he doesn't, he's not pointing this
out to me for no reason, whatever.
But what I'm saying is even when you're
saying, Hey, what do you think of this?
And I criticize something
that you work so hard on,
there's no one in the world that's happy
about that even when they ask for it.
So you have to flank people.
That's what you have to do.
Now he's asking specifically, how do
you do this? So here's some things.
What one of the things that I do when
I want to give someone criticism,
I don't give them criticism.
What I do is I ask them
questions about whatever it is.
Now this is interesting. I'm not
even talking about pointed questions.
I'm not even talking about like hard
questions. I'm Tom. I'm not saying like,
why did you do that? Yeah, I'm talking
about, hey, why did you do it that way?
Like there's a big difference
between like, Hey, well
why did you do it that way?
I mean like instead of saying, Hey, echo,
that frame is, doesn't look good. Hey,
why'd you frame that up like that?
Right?
So now I'm getting you to think about
it, right? But I'm not going to say, do,
how are you going to make that work? You
know, I'm going to say, well, hey dude,
do you think are gonna be
able to make that work?
If you did something and it doesn't go
well, I'm not going to say, you know,
did you actually think that was a
good idea? Instead, I'm going to say,
I said again, it's not pointed
question. I'm going to say, well, hey,
did that unfold the way you
thought it was going to unfold?
And now you're going to get to answer
the question. Now you're going to be the,
you're going to be the person that
uncovers the fault. It's going to be you,
not me.
And that makes it so much more palatable
to everyone when they're able to say,
oh yeah, you know, I saw this over here.
And most of the time the
person knows the truth.
Most of the time the person knows
that that thing's not framed up right.
They know that their
idea wasn't that great.
So you don't need to punch him in the
face with it cause that's actually gonna
make them get defensive. So you flank
them, you ask them the questions,
you talk about it, you
discuss the subject. And what
you do is you guide them,
you guide them to a mirror,
you guide them to a mirror.
And then I think you just have a
look in that mirror. You set them up.
So they have to look in that mirror so
that they can see the problems themselves.
And once they see the problems themselves,
they can start to correct them.
Now sometimes you, sometimes
it's your ego that wants,
even once they see the problem themselves,
do people want them to take credit
for showing that? And it's late.
You gotta you gotta check your ego.
You got to make sure that
your ego isn't saying,
I want to prove to this person that I
know how to frame this up better than
you've got to put that all in check.
You got to just let,
you've got to let them have it.
So in it now, are there situations where
you can give really good frank feedback?
Yes there is,
but you have to have a good relationship
with that person or really good,
really good relationship with that person.
And then usually one of the best ways to,
to make this happen is that the feedback,
the negative feedback is going both ways.
Meaning I want to get negative feedback
about my performance from that person so
that there's some equity in
what's being said amongst us.
Right. So I might be low, you
know, I might say, hey echo,
hey man, I, you know, I did this, uh,
I answered this core question on Qa.
Did you think that was a good
answer? Because I think, you know,
I think could've been better.
And then you say, yeah, you know,
you dragged on and talk
too long and whatever,
you give me some critique and then
I go, oh yeah, hey. And by the way,
the lighting on that didn't look good.
Right?
And so now we have a little mutual
criticism and it's all good.
It makes a little bit more palatable
to you cause I made the thing.
And so that's sometimes works.
But what's interesting
is even when you do that,
some people just don't even freaking care
and and they even after they just tear
you apart and then you throw a little
little like little nick on their shoulder,
on their arm, you give him a little
nick about something that wasn't great,
they still get from [inaudible].
So you have to be really,
you have to have a really
great relationship with that
person to be able to have
just that straight, straight
feedback. But build the relationships,
ask them questions,
let them find their own fault if you can,
and be their guide.
Let them to provide them to that mirror,
guide them to their faults.
Now of course there are some people
that won't even find their own faults,
no matter how you guide them into how
hard you try and twist them to look in the
mirror,
you have to let them know you actually
have to come out and say what's going on?
You have to be more direct. Now, luckily,
if a person is the type of person
that fails to see their own faults,
they begin to fail, right?
Because they're making mistakes.
That's why their faults, right? They're
making mistakes. And when they see that,
oh wait, when you see that and you
see that their project is failing,
or you see that there are people
are revolting against them,
or you see that they're missing deadline
after deadline, they know that too.
And then what you're doing is you're
coming to them basically as like a
concerned friend that really
wants to help them win.
And,
and pointing out some of these obvious
failures that they might not be aware of
and you still gotta be gentle about this.
But when you come to them,
you can come to them as a friend, as a,
as a person that really wants them to win.
And you can come out out of there looking
like the good guy trying to help them
get there,
their self back on track.
So those are some of the,
some of the basic strategies that I
used to help people do a little course
correction if people need a little
criticism so that they can, uh,
improve their game for themselves,
for the team, et Cetera.
Very good,
tough businessman.
My input people are, people aren't,
people aren't people don't like criticism.
Yeah. Here to tell you.
Yeah. They like praise.
You know how, and you know the other
side of this coin, if you're a person,
which you are and you don't
like criticism, which you don't,
if you can open your mind
to the criticism man,
you're going to be so you're going to
get so much better about everything that
you do.
If you can just listen to people without
getting ego crazy and thinking about
this and just listen, just listen.
Nod your head, listen to what they have
to say. They're trying to help you. Right.
We assume that they're trying to help us.
Yeah. Well listen to, I know. Oh yeah.
Are there times when they're
not? Absolutely. Yeah.
Cause you can go in with the assumption
that this person just tried to cut me
down. Well then that's not going to
get you anywhere. Yeah. Or if you're,
if you make the assumption,
you know what,
I'm going to listen to what this person
has to say. What's wrong with that? Yeah.
Even if it's an assumption and
we're not supposed to assume,
if I assume you're getting a one,
I'm gonna assume that echoes giving me
criticism right now because he wants me
to do better and I'm going to take
them as as face value as I can.
Yeah. That he is trying to
help me get better. Boom. Yeah.
And yeah,
that's actually really correct.
If you start at that point,
that's your default, right?
That, hey, this is to help.
Now I might look at your criticism and
I analyze it from a detached perspective
and I got,
I think actually echo is just trying to
drag me in the wrong direction because
he's jealous and I might
get to that point. Yeah.
And it'll be more way more obvious.
It'll be way more often.
If you started at that other place
where it's like, okay, it's here,
but if you're just default all,
he just wants to try to look like he knows
a thing or he just wants to, you know,
make, if you start out at their place to
be, yeah. You can't even kind of discern,
you know, if that really is happening or
not, not the place to let the police do.